[Music]
my next guest is a talented comedian
whose critically acclaimed new memoir
will be in stores Wednesday please
welcome the very funny
Moshe kasher hi everybody I do have a
new memoir coming out it's the story of
my troubled childhood it's called
Catcher in the Rye that really is the
title I grew up in kind of a weird I'll
tell you something about that troubled
childhood I grew up in kind of a weird
household I was raised in a deaf
household my parents were super into
hip-hop
there are sort of weird consequences to
having deaf parents both my parents are
truly deaf like growing up my mother
would need to call me on the telephone
but she couldn't use a regular phone so
she would have to do is type a message
on a computer that message would go to
an operator the operator would then call
me and that's whose voice I would hear
on the telephone which made for some
awkward conversations like reading hello
hello buzz son god no no it's your mama
call it how are you my beautiful boy mom
are you a black dude and she was my mom
was a black dude which is weird weird
for me weirder for my dad when he found
out he was very upset I don't know if it
was because of that or because my father
was death or because we were a Jewish
family but I do have fond memories of
when my father would force my brother
and I to pretend that we were also deaf
in order to get the deaf discount at the
movie theater thank you Father are you
guys familiar with the Deaf discount no
that's cuz it's not real it doesn't
exist it's something from the Jewish
parts of my father's psyche and the Deaf
parts of my father's psyche combining
together to ruin my life every time we
go to the movies same thing alright kids
would look deaf how how does one look
deaf I tried I would try looking like
I'd missed something in conversation
like
around Thanksgiving time I put a
cornucopia in my ear terrible times I
also went to rehab three times by the
time I was 15 years old in tents I
stopped smoking pot when I was 15 which
is not a popular position here in
California we recently tried to legalize
marijuana completely but it did not pass
because the Xbox doesn't have a vote
here function by the way I'm not anti
marijuana just to clarify I'm not I
think everybody should smoke pot and we
should all fail to thrive as a community
I'm on board but we do have medical
marijuana which I voted for I support it
I think it's a great thing but I do feel
like the clinics at a certain point stop
pretending to be medical clinics and not
just awesome places to get high with
your buddies you know like I'll have
like a Green Cross kind of calling back
to the arrow or they were still
pretending but then right next to it an
old-school Beastie Boys graffiti font
it's like gets your freaking smoke on
Dawg this is a weird Hospital there's a
lady here in LA she's called the 420
doctor she's one of these sort of quack
doctors that any ailment you go to her
with she'll give you a car no matter
what's the problem like I feel like
smoking weed it's like you're a perfect
candidate that sort of pales in
comparison to her motto which is the
4/20 doctor trusted and experienced for
over three years that is so few years
that is like two more years in the
smallest available amount of years
that's a math joke ladies and gentlemen
thank you guys very much
[Applause]